in the midst of the Russia scandal
Donald Trump has hired yet another
lawyer
a guy named Jay Sekulow and it was quite
an unusual choice and things with Jay
Sekulow are already really not going
well I saw an interview with him and
realized who he was because I actually
interviewed Jay Sekulow son Jordan
Sekulow on the program years ago I think
it was back in 2010 and we learned last
week from five different sources that as
a result presumably of now being under
investigation by FBI special prosecutor
Robert Muller
Donald Trump has multiple lawyers
advising him Jay Sekulow had the very
difficult task of going on Fox News
really good he went on a number of these
Sunday morning channels and having to
sort of try to argue that there's
nothing to see here with Donald Trump
being personally under investigation
while trying not to lie because again
even Donald Trump himself went on
Twitter and said yeah I am under
investigation and that very strange
tweet so Jay Sekulow shows up he's got
no experience in this type of thing and
he's basically a TV lawyer he's got a
radio show he's he's one of these
messianic Christians known as Jews for
Jesus sometimes he was born into a
Jewish family converted to Christianity
but considers himself a Messianic Jew
and these are some of the most extreme
people out there religiously and he's
worked from a legal perspective trying
to get legalized death penalty for gays
in Africa something Scott lively a guy a
pastor here from Massachusetts has
worked on we're talking about one of the
most extreme religious nuts out there in
Jay Sekulow and he was a former Fox News
legal pondan right what is it with Trump
in these Fox News lawyers he watched he
Dona Paula tano was on his short list
for the Supreme Court
that's right Trump watches Fox News and
goes out that's somebody that I should
hire to help me out here okay
so let's skip to the meat of this which
is Jay Sekulow gets interviewed on Fox
News Sunday by Chris Wallace and he's
simultaneously within within seconds
both says that Trump is under
investigation and Trump is not under
investigation and it is everything that
you would imagine it to be take a listen
to this
under investigation now do you well no
one's notified us there he is so I can't
read people's minds but I can tell you
this that we have not been notified that
there's an investigation of the
President of the United States and now
he's being investigated by the
Department of Justice because the
Special Counsel under the special
counsel regulations report still to the
Department of Justice not independent
counsel so he's being investigated you
said he is being investigated and it's
not resting anyway - no Jay and it's not
very it's not just being and so I do not
appreciate you putting words in my mouth
when I've been crystal clear that the
president is not and has not been under
investigation I don't think I could be
any clearer than that
well you don't know that he's not under
investigation again sir I mean you know
I cannot read them out you're right
Chris I can't read the mind okay so
we're in agreement you don't know
whether II don't know you don't know I
wrote about okay so he says Trump is not
under investigation then he says yeah
he's under investigation by these
specific people and then he says I've
been crystal clear here Chris no he is
not under investigation this is why
nobody wants to be Trump's lawyer
because you have to deal with Trump
tweeting offhandedly what by mere chance
seems to be the truth which is he is
under investigation and then he has to
show up and try to deny that he's under
investigation and it's also obvious why
Trump had to resort to a lawyer like
seculow because respectable law firm
said he might not pay us and he
definitely won't listen to us so we're
not taking the case and really in that
position seculow should have just said I
misspoke I didn't mean to say that Trump
was under investigation
yeah that wouldn't have looked too
pretty but it would've been a lot better
than this this is a disaster this has
been absolute is that it just just say
say you misspoke say you're not
commenting right now say it's not in the
interests of the President to talk about
a possible ongoing but almost anything
would be better than in a 15-second span
saying both that Trump is not and is
under investigation and personally I
look forward to Jay Sekulow hiring an
attorney that's really what I'm waiting
for at this point who is he going to get
to represent him in this entire thing
also credit to chris wallace for pushing
him back fine oh yeah I mean he is a Fox
News guy of cholesterol actually been
given the Russia investigation some
ample coverage yeah he is actually
somebody that
you could at least expect some semblance
of serious questions from today's
program is made possible in part by
Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30-day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s